Alright.
It took a little bit of time, but this is what I came up with.
This is the same code that we had before and really the only new
parts here are iterating through the dates and the descriptions for each job.
Here, I'm doing the same thing we did before.
I'm replacing some data from the HTML work
dates string with the dates from my work object and
then I'm appending the formatted dates to the last element of class work entry.
Same thing with description.
I'm replacing the placeholder data with work.jobs(job).description, and
then appending the formatted version to the last element of class work-entry.
And this is what we see on the page.